good evening bread in this just in from
Jake Gibson one of our intrepid
producers there in DC where he says the
Justice Department US Justice Department
officials have told Fox News that
federal charges are very much under
consideration here this as authorities
tonight are still processing that
massive crime scene not far from where I
am over at the high school also digging
deep into the 17 year old gunman's past
which were told did not raise many red
flags
prior to this morning we come together
today as we deal with one of the most
heinous attacks that we've ever seen in
the history of Texas schools an early
morning tragedy on Texas Gulf Coast
after police say a male student 17 year
old Demetrius Polk weirdest walked into
a high school art class with a shotgun
and revolver and opened fire students
say it was a scene of chaos and
confusion everybody just started running
outside and next thing you know
everybody looks in the ear boom scary I
didn't know what to think you know my
everything shot up my heart started
beating real fast I didn't know what to
do the attack happening at 7:30 Friday
morning at Santa Fe High School in the
small city of Santa Fe 35 miles
southeast of Houston
witnesses say at first they thought it
was a fire drill the fire along was just
poured and we was told to go
we got a few garden shots police say the
suspect may have been planning something
more sinister
there have been explosive devices found
in the high school and surrounding areas
this is the fourth fatal school shooting
in the United States this year those in
the city of 13,000 shocked this happened
in their community
shouldn't be going through this is my
daily life I did not feel like that and
I feel scared to even go back
investigators say that the gunman had
two weapons on him
we understand that both belonged to the
suspects father and they were legally
acquired in addition to the ten people
who lost their lives here today 10
others were seriously hurt including a
school resource officer who was shot
while trying to help the suspect
Brett tonight he is being called a hero
credited with saving many more lives
back to you Casey an arraignment for the
suspect yeah we understand that is
supposed to happen within the hour he is
in custody within Galveston County
custody and we understand that
arraignment is scheduled to happen
sometime within the next 45 minutes or
so being charged with capital murder and
aggravated assault of a police officer
in addition to what I said at the top of
the the broadcast the information coming
from JP Gibson and that the US
Department of Justice seriously
considering adding federal charges as
well here